today on the matt well show a recent cnn
article compares joe rogan's use of the
n-word to january 6th and january 6th as
we know according to the left was as bad
as 9 11. this may all seem very stupid
on the surface and it is stupid but
there's something deeper going on here
we'll talk about what that is today also
a new euphemism for rioters just dropped
it's the best one of all you got to hear
it plus the atf essentially encourages
people to make false reports against
their enemies for revenge and a gender
educator explains why you ladies are
misogynists if you don't like seeing
penises in your locker rooms and also a
model says that she doesn't need any man
because she's in love with herself will
autosexuals now be welcomed into the
lgbt alphabet camp we'll talk about that
and much more today on the matt walsh
show
[Music]
you know the thing that really defines a
room especially your living room is the
couch i mean that's that's what the room
is there for
and that's why you got to make sure you
get the best couch the best sofa
possible if you've been listening to the
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about my helix matrix heat
mattress helix has left the bedroom
though and they've started making sofas
they just launched a new company called
all form and they're already making the
best sofas we've ever seen so what makes
an all form sofa really cool for
starters it's the easiest way that you
can customize a sofa using premium
materials and at a fraction of the cost
of traditional stores you can pick your
fabric it's spill stain and scratch
resistant as well then you can pick the
color of the sofa the color of the legs
sofa size
the shape to make sure it's perfect for
you and your home usually to get a
customized furniture customized couch
that's going to cost you
an arm and a leg but that's not the case
here they've got arm chairs and love
seats all the way up to an eight seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can always start small and
buy more seats later on if you want your
all-form sofa to grow and change with
you when you move all form sofas are
also delivered directly to your door in
the past if you wanted to order a sofa
you need to hire someone to come and
assemble it in your home and break your
back try to put it together yourself
but if getting a sofa without trying in
a store sounds a little risky you don't
need to worry you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it that's more than
three months and if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
a full refund and all form is offering
20 off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com walsh to find your perfect
sofa check out allforum.com walsh
one conspiracy theory that i subscribe
to is that corporate media headlines are
created by the use of some sort of
random
current event buzzword generator and i'm
beginning to think that journalists and
news anchors themselves personally are
created in a laboratory through a
similar process and this theory was
further legitimized over the weekend
when cnn published an article with the
following headline
joe rogan's use of the n-word is another
january 6th moment
now this would have been the perfect
headline if only they'd found a way to
jam a climate change reference in there
as well as it stands i have to grade it
an 8 out of 10 pretty solid work though
cnn was embarrassed by the mockery that
followed and they soon changed the
headline to
why shrugging off joe rogan's use of the
n-word is so dangerous yes it is quite
dangerous to shrug at a word the most
dangerous kind of shrug of all in fact
but this headline is still very stupid
sadly it lacks the comedic punch of the
first headline sequels rarely live up to
the originals especially in the comedy
genre but the article itself remained
unchanged and it's worth reading some of
this
here's what it says the podcaster joe
rogan did not join a mob that forced
lawmakers to flee for their lives he
never carried a confederate flag out
inside the u.s capitol rotunda
no one died trying to stop him from
using the n-word but what joe rogan and
those that defend him have done since
videos clips of him uh using the n-word
surfaced on social media is arguably
just as dangerous as what a mob did when
they stormed the us capital on january 6
last year
of course by the way nobody died trying
to stop the capital rioters either but
who has time for such minor details
things like the truth who has time for
that nobody does it continues
rogan breached a civic norm that has
held together since world war ii it's an
unspoken agreement that we would never
return to the kind of country we used to
be
that agreement revolved around this
simple rule
a white person would never be able to
publicly use the n-word again and not
pay a price
rogan has so far paid no steep
professional price for using a racial
slur that's been called the nuclear bomb
of racial slurs and may even boost his
career that's why some
that's what some say happened to another
white entertainer who was recently
caught using the word it's a sign of how
desensitized we've become to the rising
levels of violence rhetorical and
physical in our country that rogan slur
was treated as the latest racial outrage
of the week but once we allow a white
public figure to repeatedly use the
phallus racial epithet in the english
language without experiencing any form
of punishment we become a different
crunch country we accept the
mainstreaming of a form of political
violence that's as dangerous as the
january 6th attack
now it's hard to know where to begin
first we have the casual way that words
and physical violence are equated
rhetorical violence as the author puts
it uh it may be hard for those of us
raised on these sticks and stones may
break my bones philosophy to understand
how any adult person especially a man
and i think this article was written by
an alleged man could actually claim with
any kind of straight face that a word
has done violence to him
but what you have to understand is that
we live in the age of psychological man
where a person's emotional and
psychological comfort is considered to
be the number one priority
emotional
is emotions is they're not just on par
with physical well-being but actually
they're prioritized over it this is why
for example a person who feels
distraught over their body their
biological identity is encouraged to
mutilate their body for the sake of
their psychological self-identity rather
than working to change their
psychological self-identity to better
comport with their bodies
your your psychological self-identity
your emotional well-being that is the
number one most important thing
in this context you see how a word or
idea or opinion or joke which causes
emotional discomfort becomes an even
worse form of violence
than a bullet to your head
or a blade to your stomach
but there's something else going on here
too
he says that there's a social contract a
social norm
that we've all agreed to which declares
that a white person can never say
this certain word in any context
last night's singer india arie was on
the daily show
continuing her campaign against joe
rogan and she made a similar point
listen
when you know you're doing it
and like you said in your monologue if a
person keeps doing it is that what we
call them a races so if you know you're
doing it and you keep doing it i would
say that is a racist
and so for me when i think about
want to be nice i was going to say this
name that i'm tired of saying but for me
when i think about joe rogan
i think
i think that he
is being consciously racist i mean since
the early 1900s we've had an agreement
in our society that we don't say the
word or people or you have
to suffer the consequences right and so
saying it and then being like what are
you gonna do oh sorry i didn't mean that
or i i didn't understand there was no
context under which i should say it
i don't believe that i think he knew
there was no context i think that's why
he was saying it because he got a rise
out of people that's why he would say it
he knew that it was inappropriate and i
think the fact that the fact that he did
it repeatedly and was conscious and new
i think that is
being
racist
i like how she pretends she didn't want
to say joe rogan's name i don't know i i
told myself i wasn't going to say his
name that's the only reason you're being
interviewed the whole reason you're on
the daily show to talk about joe rogan
like no one else no one wants to talk to
india re for any other reason okay
uh that's the whole reason you're there
is to talk about joe rogan and by the
way uh we should also mention with with
uh trevor noah that he you know he's
he's very much been part of this effort
to cancel joe rogan and uh
uh but
you may have seen some of the
screenshots
circulating on twitter from several
years ago
when uh trevor noah was first announced
as the replacement for um
for
uh
for the daily show for jon stewart
all of these jokes that he had made in
his past came to the surface and there
was this cancel campaign against trevor
noah and guess who came to his defense
none other than joe rogue joe rogan came
out and said hey it was just a joke
everyone back off
and to repay that trevor noah flips it
around and joins the mob against him
because that's what these people are are
made of on the left
now
we're told that there's this rule that
we all agreed to
the problem is that we did not all agree
to this rule i i didn't agree to it i
don't agree to it
i'm a part of society also and i haven't
signed any social contract which
declares that the right to use a word
any word depends on your skin pigment or
your country of origin
i don't agree to any rule which allows a
member of one racial group to say a word
six thousand times a day if they want
while a member of another
group cannot utter it in any context at
all no matter what
i don't agree to any rule which says
that context doesn't matter when it
comes to language context always matters
you cannot know what anyone is saying or
understand anyone's meaning if you
ignore context
context is always important
in fact she
she
uh contradicts herself in what she's
saying right there because she says oh i
uh he he used the word that he knew was
offensive and he said it because he was
trying to get a rise out of people
okay well if you think that was the
context that he was trying to get a rise
out of people and he was just saying it
because it's offensive and he's trying
to get attention
i don't know if that's true or not but
if that's true that means it's not
racist
that means his intention was not to be
racist it was just to get attention or
to be offensive for the sake of being
offensive
that you could say what you want about
someone doing that but it's not racist
it's just it's that's the motivation
according to you
well the context doesn't matter
i also have not consented to whatever
consequences cnn or india re or trevor
noah
you know think ought to be doled out to
the violators of this agreement that i
never signed
i don't agree to any of it
most everyone in the country has not
agreed to any of this
and that's because it's not our rule
it's not society's rule
it's their rule
the leftist elite have come up with
these social directives these kind of
cultural regulations
and they demand adherence
and we'll attempt to punish anyone who
does not adhere
what we have to understand is that to
the leftist elite
their social edicts and ordinances are
the most important rules the most sacred
law the only law really
this is part of the reason why they've
given up on enforcing the actual written
law
the law that says you can't do stuff
like you know rob and kill people
partly they've abandoned that kind of
law and order because they want to
destabilize civilization but also
their heart isn't in it
all that matters to them is that you
follow their rules
rules against hurting and killing people
i mean physically hurting and killing
people not emotionally hurting and
killing them
they've been in place in every
civilization in one form or another
since the dawn of time
the left cannot claim credit for those
rules didn't invent them
and thus doesn't care about them
so they're not emphasized
and sometimes are directly and
purposefully de-emphasized
for example a woman in new york
named christina yuna lee was murdered
inside her apartment by a homeless
drifter just last week the daily mail
has some of the details it says a
homeless serial criminal accused of
murdering an ad creative after following
her into her apartment
um knifed the woman 40 times with one of
her own knives and had a sexual motive
for doing so a court heard assamad nash
was charged with sexually motivated
burglary by prosecutors on monday as was
revealed his victim christina yuna lee
was found topless in the bathtub of her
chinatown apartment on sunday the charge
suggests a possible motive for the
brutal murder which shocked nyc and
raised fresh questions about new york
state's bail reforms after was revealed
that nash was a serial criminal on bail
for robbery when he allegedly
did the killing well of course he was on
bail that's the detail you can always
count on finding in any of these stories
about violent scumbags randomly
assaulting or killing innocent people
they're always on bail
now it turns out that nash had a lengthy
rap sheet stretching back years he's
been a violent worthless societal leech
for a long time but here are the
highlights from just the past year
says according to court records access
by dailymail.com nash has been arrested
four times in the last year alone his
rap sheet included misdemeanor charges
of assault intentional damage to
property harassment resisting arrest
both attempted and successful escape
from police officers and selling a fare
card
three of these cases remain open and he
has appeared in court on numerous
occasions he was set to appear again
before a judge on march 9 on the assault
harassment and intentional damage to
property charges
now it doesn't matter how often this
sort of thing happens
the left will keep pushing for things
like bail reform
ensuring that more and more violent
criminals are put back on the street
even after they've been arrested because
these rules are not their rules
they quite sincerely feel more outrage
about joe rogan saying a naughty word
than they do about a woman getting
stabbed to death in her apartment by a
drug-addled vagrant not only because the
vagrant's race makes him still a victim
according to their narrative but also
because the vagrant didn't break any
rule that they invented
he violated a different code the legal
code
for one
but also the moral code written in our
hearts by natural law and codified by
every human civilization since time
immemorial
they don't care about that
what matters most is their rule book
which they came up with
and which they add to every day
and whose violators they believe
should pay the harshest penalty of all
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
did you know that right now you could be
paying a lot less for your home it's
true and it really isn't that difficult
to make it happen i mean mortgage rates
are still incredibly low chances are you
can benefit i'm telling you this is your
chance to save hundreds maybe even up to
a thousand dollars a month you've just
got to call american financing america's
home for home loans take advantage of a
free mortgage review and learn about
custom loans that can save you big money
no pressure no obligation no upfront or
hidden fees you decide what's best for
your budget and their salary based
mortgage consultants are going to help
make it happen as well it really is that
easy and if you start soon you could
skip up to two payments to begin with
saving money that way as well
and you may close in as fast as 10 days
call 866 569-4711
if you want to make sure that you're
saving money on your mortgage and saving
money in your budget as well every
single month call again
866-569-4711 that's 866-569-4711
one more time 866
569-4711 or apply online
americanfinancing.net american financing
nmls one eight two three three four nmls
consumeraccess dot org
all right so you know i uh i don't want
to get too sappy here on a tuesday but i
have to tell you that um you know i love
my wife i like to show her how much i
appreciate her and um i might not be the
most romantic guy in the world but but
last night for valentine's day
and i'm not trying to brag either you
know if there's any women listening i
don't want you to feel um like you're
like your your husband or your boyfriend
is is somehow insufficient because of
what i'm going to tell you i'm not
trying to make anyone jealous but
i decided to do something a little
special on valentine's day and i took my
wife to crack her barrel last night
a bit of a splurge i realize
but i said to my wife you know what you
deserve this you and and i told you to
get anything you want from the menu
um you want to get the you want to get
the fried chicken you want to get you
want to go with the three side
special instead of just the two sides go
for it okay
because i'm here to take care of you
and uh so that's what we did and i'm
totally serious by the way it's not a
joke this that's where we went last
night for valentine's day um we had the
kids with us so we couldn't we couldn't
find a babysitter you know
so what are you gonna do you're gonna
try to go to a nice fancy like uh candle
lit dinner when you've got four kids
with you it's impossible
so uh we went to cracker barrel my wife
had to had to leave uh mid meal also to
change our daughter's diaper because she
pooped in her diaper
and um
i couldn't do that because i you know i
don't know how to change diapers so she
just had to do it and it was great we
played the little triangle game the
little triangle peg game that they have
at the table we walked around the gift
shop a little bit afterwards
uh we lectured my son for not eating his
chicken tenders even though i spent
literally four dollars on them
so it was a great great meal and the
thing is i'm sitting there in cracker
barrel
on valentine's day
and on one hand i find it hilarious the
whole situation
on the other hand i maybe feel a little
slight amount of shame
because it is valentine's day and i am
with my wife a cracker barrel and
there's like almost nobody else there
like and usually
you know this when you go to cracker
barrel any time of day any any day of
the year the place is packed
there's nobody else there almost nobody
else
and so i'm kind of working through this
in my head and then one of the one of
the waitresses comes over and says hey
are you matt walsh
and the manager comes and another
employee and it was a whole crowd and
they you know they asked me for an
autograph i think i autographed one of
the menus
and my wife loved every single minute of
it by the way she kept trolling me by
suggesting
things that she knew i wouldn't want to
do she's like oh you want to get the
other employees we could all take a big
group picture with matt
so that's how it went um
and she asked them she said that she
says oh just does cracker barrel have a
celebrity wall we could take his picture
and put it up there
it's like yeah i'll be up there with the
local weatherman you know and the guy
who runs the car dealership down the
street
um it was good though i'm a man of the
people i don't talk to people but i'm a
man of the people and it's funny
sometimes because you know i'll be i i
am sometimes accused of being in elitist
like out of touch
oh you're an out of touch elitist media
person dude i shop at walmart and i go
to cracker barrel with my family on
valentine's day that's what i do
i have changed literally not one single
part of who i am or what i do
and by the way i put up a picture
yesterday uh last night
because i decided the secret was out
anyway so i might as well i might as
well just run with it and i took a
picture of my wife at cracker barrel and
i posted it to twitter
you know announcing all of this
and uh but it was up for about 20
minutes i did take it down because my
wife looked at the picture not because
she was ashamed we were at cracker
barrel but because she didn't like the
way she looked in the picture and so i
had to take it down
and like my wife when it comes to
pictures she'll she inspects them very
very closely
she sees one oh my eyelash is a little
bit crooked there i got to take it down
so any unsanctioned picture of her that
makes its way
anywhere publicly that's a problem so
and that's how valentine's day ended for
us it was great very romantic night all
right um
so speaking of valentine's day you know
there are many people who think that our
federal law enforcement agencies are
corrupt out of control
full of lunatics
and this isn't going to do anything to
negate those concerns so let's put up
what the what the atf decided to tweet
on valentine's day
so this is atf headquarters their
official account on twitter
and they say valentine's day can still
be fun even if you broke up do you have
information about a former or current
partner involved in illegal gun activity
let us know and we'll make sure it's a
valentine's day to remember
and then they have a little faux
valentine's day card there it says got
an ex who buys or sells guns illegally
we would love to meet and treat them to
a valentine's day surprise
okay i'll remind you again this is not
some kooky kind of
anti-gun organization that put this out
there or anything like that this is the
atf that tweeted this from their
official account
and they're encouraging you to make out
of out of jealousy or revenge to make
reports
of criminal activity on on people that
you know
so they can get basically encouraging
swatting this is um this is a not so
veiled attempt to encourage
false reports also
because how are people going to take
that
if anyone sees that and they're as
psychotic as the atf apparently hopes
that they are
and they're gonna think oh okay well you
know i've got a i've got
a husband who cheated on me and he left
me and i hate him for that maybe maybe
i'll go ahead and call that tip line
that they provided
he might have illegal guns or not
and if he gets killed in the ensuing
raid then hey it's all it's all all a
benefit in the end
this is what our government agencies are
now encouraging
to call and report someone
for revenge
really whether the report is true or not
amazing
well i wish i could say that i'm amazed
by it but i'm not quite
here's another thing that's not amazing
but it is great in its own way after the
super bowl win in los angeles people of
course started rioting
and let's play let's play first the news
report on this um take a look at 6b
take a look at this this is downtown la
where super bowl victory celebrations
have gotten out of hand and kco 9's
desmond shaw is live overhead in sky 9.
and i believe that's a metro bus
desmond and people are climbing on top
of it what's going on there
yeah this just happened seconds ago here
chris and leslie quite raucous here on
uh grand between 11th and 12th now lapd
was trying to disperse the crowd to the
south and then everyone just kind of
headed north uh into this really thick
traffic and there's not very much of an
lapd presence so now they're climbing on
top of this bus they're lighting off the
fireworks we saw some vehicles here that
we're doing some really intense burnouts
with huge clouds of smoke coming up in
the area and so yeah this is a new
development now somebody up on top of
this looks like someone spray-painted so
then you'd also see them sure they're
they're rocking that other car they're
trying to knock it over i mean as far as
as far as riots this is how bad it is
now los angeles as far as riots go you
see that you think yeah you know it's
it's we've seen a lot that's that i'm
not sure that makes it into the top 20.
um and there is this i will i will never
understand yeah i don't understand the
inclination to riot at all
um
but especially
because you're
happy that something happened that you
you liked your football team won and
you're rioting because of that i don't i
don't quite understand the psychology of
it maybe it's good that i don't
understand the psychology of it but uh
there's no question that that's a riot
you're in the street you're trying to
tip cars over you're climbing on cars
that's a riot that's what that is um but
we know that with the media
they are very very selective about what
things they will call a riot
and they've only met in the last
i don't know this century they've only
encountered one riot that they would
call a riot which was january 6
except that that they can't help
themselves and that goes beyond riot now
they call it insurrection terrorist
attack whatever else
um
but this
you know because it's not it's it's
you can't pin this on conservatives
um
it looks to be a racial mix in the crowd
there but certainly plenty of non-white
people so that means the media can't
call it a riot so what are they gonna
call it here's cbs los angeles they say
problem
hold on
problematic celebrators
were seen jumping on top of a white
pickup truck as police tried to disperse
the crowd
lapd declared unlawful assembly almost
45 minutes before
problematic
celebrators
so we know about the mostly peaceful
protest
okay we know about the people that
burn a cvs to the ground run inside a
foot lock or run out with with a arm you
know an arm full of of stolen shoes
that's all protesters
well it wasn't was it was a problem i
guess for the media because they can't
call these protesters they're not
protesting they're happy they're happy
they're celebrating
so what are we going to call them
problematic celebrators
you all you you almost have to
appreciate it for the humor of nothing
else
if you want another good laugh here's
larry hogan on cnn he was
interviewed on cnn and he's the by the
way the governor of uh
maryland
uh
uh
you know
base basically i guess we would call
them a moderate a moderate republican
and uh and we call him moderate
republicans but because he spends most
of his time attacking people on the
right criticizing the right and he
doesn't like donald trump and that's why
he gets to go on cnn and they interview
him they give him a friendly interview
but here he is talking about his
potential presidential run listen
that's a nice video it just lacked the
hogan 2024 uh banner at the bottom are
you considering a presidential run well
we put out great videos like that almost
every week that was uh taken from my
state of the state address last week and
and it's pretty well done but like i
said i'm going to be i'm going to run
through the tape as governor till
january of next year
i'm going to try to be the very best
governor i can be i'm going to continue
to stand up and be a voice i'm not going
to sit back and not be involved in the
issues of the day i'm concerned about
the direction of the party in the
country and i'll make a decision about
2024 after i finish this job so you are
considering it so we're certainly going
to take a look at it after january of
23. what makes you think that there's uh
a lane for a
moderate-ish uh blue state anti-trump
sane republican like you when you look
at your party right now well you know i
consider myself a common sense
conservative i have been lifelong
republican uh i believe that that's
where most people in america are about
70 percent of the people in america are
completely frustrated with politics on
both sides republicans and democrats and
latest cnn poll came out and said you
know right now only 50
of the republicans would like to see
donald trump run again i believe that
there is a pretty large lane of sane
republicans uh and they're looking for a
voice
that's good i mean it would need to be a
large lane
um for him but
yeah
there is certainly a lane for someone
who's not donald trump to run for
president like for example ron santos uh
and and and other
there are other
not many but there is a group a very
small group of republicans who i think
number one would be
would be good presidents and they'd
they'd have a chance maybe of beating
donald trump in the primary though maybe
not a very good chance
um
where does larry hogan fit into that
well he doesn't fit at all you have to
appreciate the of course very
unbiased objective way that the question
was framed is there room for a sane
republican like you and you're of course
you're saying because you don't like
donald trump that's the only
thing that matters that's the only
litmus test here as far as jake tapper
is concerned
um
is there room for him no there's not
you know moderate republican you spend
most of your time attacking people on
the right
you spend most of your time trying to
appeal to people on the left
there's no room at all
and this is the problem that you wish
moderate republicans would
would realize
you know this is the obstacle that
they're going to come up against
is that
if you're trying to appeal to the left
well you might be able to appease them a
little bit
but
there's always going to be someone
farther to your left they don't they
don't need you
why would they vote for you they could
just they could get the real deal
and if it's a general election
presidential election
and you're trying to appeal to people on
the left well
they could they could vote for the
leftist republican or the leftist
democrat why would they go with a
republican
or you have people on the right who are
sick and tired of people like you so
you're appealing to almost nobody
and it's not because it's not because
you're a voice in the wilderness crying
out it's not because you're staying firm
on your principles and all of that
it's because you're trying to find this
middle lane
between the right and then over here on
the left
which advocates for pure
unadulterated evil
and you're trying to find kind of a try
to find a lane that isn't exactly true
but isn't totally false
and we'll have more about that in the
daily cancellation coming up uh another
clip i want to play for this is
representative pramila jayapal
she is i don't think she's quite in the
squad but she's she's sort of a
you know she's a rotating she's a sixth
man kind of figure in the squad and uh
they they bring her in sometimes to talk
about some of these issues
and here she is saying that unmasked
members of congress are undermining
democracy somehow listen
this is where the lack of civility has
come to in the united states congress
and i think it is a massive problem it
undermines our ability to get work done
and it is intolerable in a workplace
where we are going to work to do the
work of the american people and also let
me just remind your viewers that this
was about wearing a mask which is
mandated
in the capital it is mandated in the
capital and it is to protect our safety
our collective safety the safety of our
staffers and so the idea that and this
has happened to me where you get on an
elevator and people refuse to wear a
mask and your choices are to either get
off the elevator or to get on the
elevator and to tell them to wear a mask
that
that should not be a problem in the
united states congress and uh i really
believe that our colleagues who refuse
to even adhere to the basic norms of
civility are undermining our democracy
and of course we're seeing it in all
kinds of even more serious ways like the
january 6th insurrection is is just part
of that and part of the attempt to take
down a legitimate democracy from
functioning
um
you know she she is an attractive woman
so you know i'll say that for
at least but
by not putting a mask on you're it's an
attack on our institution it's an attack
on democracy we're destroying democracy
by not wearing a mask and it's just like
january 6.
once again the random buzzword generator
you got to ram uh january 6th into it
how does any of this make sense i mean
in what way does a person a person not
wearing a mask in an elevator
is undermining democracy
what
but of course
none of these people are ever asked
it's one of my great frustrations
you know there's a lot of questions you
could ask people like this that they
wouldn't be able to answer i'd love for
people to ask but and they're not but
pretty much no matter what they're
talking about
one of the most basic questions you
could ask is just what
what
what is that supposed to mean exactly
explain that
you're making a lot of assertions
so i heard all of your assertions that a
person not wearing a mask in an elevator
is is undermining democracy explain what
you mean by that exactly
can you go into greater detail
and they're never asked to do that
because the person conducting the
interview knows
that they wouldn't be able to explain it
these are just bald assertions
just like these people are canons
projecting assertions shooting
assertions all over the place and uh but
you can never stop and pick any one of
them up and say what was this again what
did you mean by this
because they won't be able to explain it
because it's total nonsense
all right this is from a really
important story here from the new york
post
it says a model has claimed that she
doesn't need a boyfriend because she's
so in love with herself
uh
luanna sandian said that she is
autosexual which is a self-love
relationship that can go beyond the
erotic sphere the divorced model adds
that she doesn't need a boyfriend to
experience sexual pleasure pleasure and
revealed that she will even be happy
enjoying valentine's day alone
she says being autosexual as i see it is
along the same lines as being an
independent person
luanna claimed that she's not thinking
about having a relationship with someone
else at the moment she continued i found
myself single it's the best thing a
woman can do for herself
and she explains what autosexuality is
she says it means i'm attracted to
myself i always felt that way i just
didn't know there was a name for it
and then she continues and this was
interesting
it's nice to know i'm not crazy or a
massive narcissist it's something real
that a lot of people experience it was
very important to find out that i'm not
alone
as sexy as that may sound and it is it's
kind of self-love on steroids there was
always a part of me that thought it was
weird so it's nice to have this
statement that it's normal
and so we see the same process
carried out yet again which of course by
the way this it is narcissism i mean
it's like pretty much the definition of
narcissism
um being literally in love with yourself
i would be interested in seeing the the
headline 10 years from now
uh you know the headline now is model
claim she doesn't need a boyfriend
because she's so in love with herself
ten years from now the the the headline
is x-model
says that she's alone and miserable
because of rampant misogyny you know
that's gonna be the headline ten years
from now because the thing that these
women don't understand is that um
your youth and your beauty
all of that fades
pretty quickly
and it's just one of the sad realities
of being a mortal human being
um and we're being introduced to a lot
of the realities of being a mortal human
being in the last few years and people
don't seem to like any of them and
that's just it's it's true a lot of it
is is really not not very fun but
another one of those realities along
with the fact that you're going to die
the other one is that if you live
kind of a normal length of life
most of your life you're gonna is gonna
be spent
not youthful and physically beautiful
the majority of your life
you'll you will be in that state
so what you have right now is
very temporary and very fleeting
and if that's if that's all you are
if that's the only thing you care to
cultivate
then once that goes you're going to have
nothing
and when you're walking around now and
saying well i don't doesn't matter
because i'm i'm young i'm beautiful
i don't need to try to impress anybody i
don't need companionship with anybody
people are fawning over me
you know when you act that way
eventually that goes away you you lose
the youth and beauty but people remember
what a miserable person you are and so
you've alienated everyone in your life
you don't have your beauty to fall back
on and now you're going to spend the
rest of your life just alone miserable
and that's what it's going to be
but she also says how um
how well okay i i'm in love with myself
i'm very obsessed with myself all i care
about is myself
so she's divorced her marriage didn't
work out big shocker there
and then she says that
she she went i guess on the internet as
people do
and she discovered that there's a name
for the there's a label
and that other people
feel the same way she does about
themselves
and just discovering that discovering
that she's she's not alone which is kind
of ironic because she says that she
wants to be alone yet it was she wants
to be alone she's okay being alone yet
it was very important to her
that she's not alone in feeling this
this way at the same time so she wants
to be alone but she also doesn't want to
be alone
so you find that that tension there
um and so it's important for her to find
out that there are other people
in this
quote unquote community and that there's
a label for it
and the minute you can label it
and you discover that there are other
people that carry the same label that
that in your mind that legitimizes it
and that makes it a legitimate
identity
and thus an identity that deserves to be
celebrated and probably we should take
auto sexual if they're not already and
add them to the to the alphabet lgbtqia
maybe is autosexual one of the a's
that's already in there i don't know
and we see this is this is the same
process we've seen many times
where you take people they they you know
they have a a certain compulsion
a compulsion that they should be
resisting and suppressing in her case
it's a compulsion towards
obsessive selfishness that's a it's bad
okay people might experience it but it's
bad you should try to suppress it
try to be a better person
you should try to develop some virtue
um
and maybe in a different time someone
like herself that's what she would have
done
because she would have assumed that
there's something wrong with feeling
this way she would assume that she's the
only one she's not going to go out in
public and talk to people face to face
and say hey i'm in love with myself and
i'm the only person i care about she
would never say that to someone
so she would feel that shame and she
would feel the need to change herself
and she would change maybe
but now because of the internet
whatever compulsion you feel you could
just go
google it
uh discover that there are other people
in that quote community
that there's even a fancy label for it
and now rather than suppressing this and
maybe getting over it becoming a better
person now you've embraced it
and it begins to sort of eat you alive
and it's the only thing about you it's
your entire identity
so the same old story we've
the same song we've we've heard many
times before
40 years ago ronald reagan saw massive
inflation unlike anything the country
had ever seen before until today in
reagan's own words inflation is as
violent as a mugger as frightening as an
armed robber and as deadly as a hitman
right now your retirement accounts are
under attack thanks to the inflationary
policies of this administration
if you've not yet called birch gold the
only people i trust to help you
diversify your 401ks and iras into cold
then you're missing the boat now's the
time to act actually you're treading
water without a life fast that's how bad
it is birch gold has your life vest and
they're going to make it very easy for
you let them help you convert an ira or
401k into a tax sheltered ira in gold
with thousands of satisfied customers
and an a plus rating with the better
business bureau you can trust birch gold
to protect your savings all you got to
do is text walsh to 98 98 98 to get a
free info kit on gold reagan knew better
than anyone but the biggest threat to
our wealth and what it was is inflation
and you could protect your wealth now
all you got to do is text walsh to 98
98.98 to get your free info kit now
let's get now to the
comment section
dailywire.com sweet baby comments if you
want to leave a video comment let's
start with uh clip eight
hey matt i just wanted to respond to
your criticism of that super bowl
commercial for the google pixel six
you know i understand that with your
white privilege you just can't
understand and grasp the difficulty that
people of color go through when trying
to take a simple photo or video you know
you just don't have their shared
experience and i would really expect
more from the world's leading lgbtq plus
author
peace
that was a there was an angel on earth
that left that comment
and he was he was
subsumed back up into heaven as he was
speaking
uh that's a shame because that was that
was a a brilliant but if you're if
you're just listening on audio you can't
appreciate what just happened there and
i think i think if i explain the joke
it'll ruin it so we're just going to
move on you'll have to go to youtube or
something and see the video there um
well done though all right we got one
more here let's let's watch this
oh just a photo okay uh
this is from alex's my dad's a huge fan
and he drew this just for you and then
there's a picture of me and i actually
look decent in the picture i appreciate
that see that's that's that's what i
know about myself is i always look i
like when people draw pictures of me
which may sound might sound narcissistic
but that's because that's the only time
where i look
passable where i don't look hideous it's
always in the photographs which as we've
discovered it's because it's not it's
it's not me it's the camera is the
problem
all right this is from emily she says at
this point you can only be mad at the
people
come on the elite have been nothing but
open about their stance do what i say
not what i do
the issue is the people
yeah emily this is never going to be
a popular stance to take
but i
largely agree with you this is why i
could also never really call myself a
populist because i'm way too skeptical
of the populace
i'm skeptical of the elites too
certainly
but
much of what is happening it's because
we have allowed it to happen
and that's a broad statement because it
applies to almost every area of the
culture
you know what whatever's happening as a
conservative whatever's happening in the
culture in whatever area whether we're
talking about education we're talking
about our civil liberties being taken
away whatever it is
um it has required the silence
in order in order for it to happen and
for it to exist it's required the
silence of many
people in fact we used to we used to
brag all the time about the the silent
majority
because we were very proud of the
majority part but no one ever stopped to
say what about the site what's up with
the silence though that's actually
shameful to be in the majority and yet
remain silent
and we remain silent for so long that
now you know i don't even think we're in
the majority anymore
um
person good username there says
apparently eminem was kneeling out of
respect for tupac but this hasn't been
confirmed so no one truly knows what he
knelt for and another comment says
eminem didn't take an e during the
anthem he took a knee when the other
dude played a tupac song he took a knee
out of respect for tupac
uh
yeah this is
this is this is the argument that i've
heard this is the rationalization and
there were a lot of comments like this
that oh no he was just he was taking a
knee for tupac
what first of all why would he be doing
that in the first place but no this was
100 it was a statement for colin
kaepernick
in fact the story is that eminem said
ahead of time or told the nfl that he
wanted to do this and then the nfl kind
of shook their fingers finger at him and
said no no no don't do that just tink we
don't we don't want you to do that
wink wink and then he went ahead and did
it anyway
right
so so that you know it's the best of
both worlds for the nfl so they could
get the political statement that they
that they like and then it appeals to
those people um to that to that side of
the political aisle
but then also the nfl can say oh but we
didn't want him to do that and then
that's supposed to satiate people on the
right
so that was the plan there but it's 100
a fact that he was doing this
for uh colin kaepernick but but it also
shows just how absurd the whole knee
thing is because it it it's such a vague
statement
and it
the meaning behind it continues to morph
so originally it was supposed to be
about police brutality and then it
became this kind of generalized protest
against america as a whole
and then it became different things and
then eminem does it and it's to honor
colin kaepernick but now we're told that
oh no he's also honoring tupac too
so just throw it all in there
just it's kind of a it's the grab bag of
political statements i guess
you know if you missed the world
premiere of shut-in this past weekend
head to dailywire.com subscribe and get
a membership today it's not too late of
course to watch that film or any of our
other content the film is now
exclusively streaming for daily wire
members and currently has a critic score
of a hundred percent and an audience
score of 97 on rotten tomatoes there's a
shocker we are creating more and more
great entertainment without a leftist
agenda and it's all thanks to our daily
wire members
so head to dailywire.com subscribe today
so you can watch shut in also hyperions
and gina's new movie out this summer all
that's coming up
and if you're a candace owens fan yes we
can this merch is back in stock and
ready for your shipping
and shopping pleasure she's also added
brand new merch that is very limited the
restock includes a new line of posters
heavy duty short sleeves and long sleeve
t-shirts when she launched the line in
december her initial merch release sold
out in just two days her autograph hats
sold out in hours so don't wait or this
new collection might be gone all of
these items and much more you can check
out now at yes we candice.com also go to
dailywire.com
you can get my merchandise too when it
comes to understanding how our world is
run there's always more to uncover
introducing one of the daily wires
newest projects the enemy within our new
series featuring acclaimed journalist
lee smith author of the plot against the
president um in his newest project smith
uncovers a political coup orchestrated
by america's ruling elites to generate
their own wealth and power at the
expense of the american people's safety
and freedom from fouchy to our
educational system to hollywood and
everything in between each episode will
take you deep behind the scenes to
expose what those who are supposed to be
protecting you
don't want you to know the enemy within
will start streaming this friday
exclusively at the daily wire now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel someone who up to this
point has somehow never made it into the
daily cancellation i don't think that
would be david french ostensibly a
conservative columnist
uh once of the national review and now
of the never trump publication the
dispatch now i hesitate to describe
anything as never trump because it's
ridiculous to still define people that
way with trump no longer even in office
in fact never trump stopped having
logical relevance after he won the
primaries in 2016.
six years later though the label still
somehow applies because people like
french still choose to define themselves
by their opposition to the former
president but it goes beyond trump for
french and people on his team
opposition to trump has long since
turned into opposition to opposition to
an obsessive focus on whatever they
consider to be the far right
though french and company continue to
call themselves conservatives members of
the right
they dedicate most of their time in
nearly everything that they write to
attacking those who are further on the
right than themselves
now there's nothing wrong with holding
your own side accountable i criticize
republicans all the time i'm doing it
right now
but the problem is that there is this
certain element
which seems to have almost entirely
given up on opposing the left for them
the great villains in our country public
enemies number one are the people on
their own side
which makes you wonder if they're really
on our side at all
in david french's case he has made it a
special mission of late to criticize
right-wing evangelicals and his new
tradition it seems is to publish a
weekly screed calling evangelicals to
task on sunday it always publishes it on
sunday so why while they're all at
church
french hits them with another uppercut
the latest from this past sunday um
published on dispatch makes the case
that right-wing evangelicals are the the
most dangerous radicals in the country
in fact french said exactly this he
shared his column to twitter with this
caption
where are america's most dangerous
political radicals
rallying in churches by the thousands in
city after city in church after church
the seeds for the next insurrection are
being sown by the mega-christian
nationalists
right before our eyes
now the article proceeds over the course
of some 2000 words to expose what french
calls mega christian nationalism
this is what he a supposed conservative
considers to be the most dangerous
political movement in the country
he talks about the groups of
evangelicals who remain steadfastly
loyal to donald trump
they believe the election was stolen
they think that trump is uh in some
cases you know is the only one who can
rescue the nation
he describes something called the
reawaken america tour which stops at
venues across the country often churches
and features michael flynn and
presumably other speakers
doing sort of a mix of apocalyptic
preaching and political activism
and there are people in this group
who attend those events that french
describes who believe that trump is
still the president and are prone to buy
into various theories about how trump
will eventually re-emerge as the true
leader and president of the country
those claims were a lot more popular in
the first eight months of the biden
administration propagated by people like
sydney powell and lynn lynnwood they
seem to have died away a little bit
but still this is the kind of thing
we're talking about and which french has
set his sights on and considers to be
one of the great crises we face as a
society and the most dangerous threat
now
i agree with david french that a lot of
this stuff is pretty weird
i also don't think that donald trump is
our savior or ever was
i don't think that any man is our savior
um especially not donald trump
i don't think he's the answer
in 2024 i think it's time to move on
from him and start looking at guys like
desantis though even with desantis i
hope that he never develops the kind of
cult of personality that trump had and
in some cases still has around himself
i think we should retain a healthy
skepticism towards all politicians
but
the idea that any of this represents
some great existential threat to the
united states is laughable
and the claim that devoted trump fans
are the most dangerous political
radicals in the country is not only
wrong but reprehensible
it's the kind of thing that only a very
stupid person could possibly believe and
david french is not stupid
if he's not stupid that means that he is
as a christian himself choosing to make
fellow christians into the targets into
sort of human shields
to cover
for the people who are truly the most
dangerous
and who are those people
well the worst thing that mega christian
nationalists as french calls them ever
did was january 6th and that was not an
insurrection or the worst day in
american history or anything close to
either of those but it was bad and it
was stupid it was a riot
and there really is no context where a
riot is ever a smart strategy or the
right thing to do especially not a riot
at the capitol
but let's flip it over now to the other
side and ask the same sort of question
what's the worst thing
that leftist radicals have ever done
well
they have for one thing facilitated and
funded the slaughter of 60 million human
children since roe v wade
i would think that that already puts
them in a league far beyond the idiots
who took an unsanctioned tour of the
capitol building
does david french not believe
that the 60 million babies who were
killed uh who've been killed
are legitimate human beings
he says he's pro-life if he is then he
must believe that they're human beings
and if he does then he cannot possibly
think that magga people are more
dangerous than those who are carrying
out the mass slaughter of infants
and it doesn't end there
what else have leftist radicals done
they've waged an all-out assault on law
and order they've intentionally plunged
our cities into anarchy and violence
they've fomented not just one instance
of rioting but entire summer of it
and they've excused and encouraged the
endemic looting that now happens in many
of these same cities they've torn down
statues and monuments they've tried to
rewrite history they've lied repeatedly
about the issue of police brutality
intentionally putting cops in harm's way
getting many of them killed
they've embedded radical gender ideology
into our school system they've
indoctrinated millions of kids into it
they sent millions of kids plummeting
into confusion and internal chaos
so they're agents of chaos both
externally and internally
they chemically castrate little boys
they chop the breasts off of 15 year old
girls
they mutilate and destroy and kill they
prey on the most vulnerable
we haven't even talked about how they've
used kovid to erase our civil liberties
or how they use blackmail and
intimidation and the mob to silence and
shame anyone who criticizes their agenda
they also use outright lies and slander
for example as it happens
right now as we speak leftists are
photoshopping fake tweets and posting
them to twitter claiming that i wrote
them this has happened more than once
and not just small accounts spreading
these tweets either it's a coordinated
effort to smear and silence me this is
what they do this is who we're dealing
with
the most dangerous i mean there's no
context or contest i should say
there are some weirdos on the right
there are also gullible people who
unfortunately get suckered by con
artists like lynn wood and his ilk
but gullible people and weird people
exist everywhere
that that's not why our civilization is
imploding
it's imploding due to the conscious
efforts
of radical leftists
who are who are not congregating in
suburban churches
but who hold positions of power
and who control every major institution
in the country
because you know that's the other thing
about these uh
people that go reawaken america with
michael flynn or whatever the other
thing about them
is that you can say whatever you want
about what they believe and what they're
saying
these people are not in positions of
power okay they're not running the
government
um they're not running facebook
they're not running big tech they don't
run hollywood
they don't run anything institutionally
you know the people that run these
institutions they're the danger they're
the threat
and if you aren't focused primarily on
fighting that war against those people
then we're not on the same side
and that's why today david french is
finally canceled and we'll leave it
there for today thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavo vadowsky
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
justin trudeau suspends civil liberties
in canada to stop the freedom convoy
washington dc lifts its draconian
vaccine mandate and the new york times
gets away with defaming sarah palin
check it out on the michael knowles show